herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
auch meine kanal zu dann mit dem typen
auf der anderen seite der pakte an
damit macht was wir machen heute die
lügen oder nicht verwenden dieter körner
haben wir sagen wir beide gegenstände
mitgebrachten werden gleich wieder einen
gegenstand nach oben holen beschreiben
oder lügen und der gegenüber red okay
sagt die wahrheit hat er das wirklich
oder erfunden gerne challenge bestrafung
ist auf diesem planeten weiter zu
existieren in meinem video es schlag auf
schlag weiter etwas wissen und beim
schlechtes und 50 100 oder 50 dass ein
video von ihr müsst aber jetzt schon
[Musik]
okay mag dagegen ständig hier in meinen
händen hilfe ist ein dickes fettes couch
schiffen okay für ich bisher bei lukas
video aufgenommen hatte er alle sachen
immer mitgebracht damit wieder unter
anderen gucken ob erzählen die vielen
kleinen fortschritten dickes hätte
[Musik]
okay das ziel schon weiter ist als
punkte nach 50 1 punkten
ich würde 10
ich halte in meiner hand eine kerze eine
kerze als würde ich weiß auf jeden fall
hier den raum mehrere kerzen stehen ich
bin mir halten nur nicht sicher ob bei
über zehn schlafzimmern an ob du im
schlaglicht herzen gehabt erklärte ich
würde sagen ja du hast bekehrten der
anwalt decke zu faltern eingekehrt
ich kehre er hat in einem verein
hünstetten luca 11
okay das ist hier eine schulung eine
einlage von den beiden gehört hast du
die möglichkeit eine umgedrehte
psychologie
für den s&p informationen verbreite gute
wird oder keine altkreis mit und wird
angefangen 5 ich halte in meiner hand
einer kartoffel eine kartoffel
der mieter umgelegt hat mich auch
umdrehen was abgeschaut auf die schale
noch da ist die erinnerung verblasst
eine kartoffel und mich viele kannten
führt 3 1
ich würde empfehlen probleme nach
gefühlen aber häufig software schon für
die tausende
ich habe in meiner hand einen
staubsauger auf das mögliche endlager
von zu hause mitgebracht die er
irgendwie hinzubekommen ich sage du hast
ein
alle familien nur noch eine gehabt ihr
ein bei mir war folglich bekommt man
konstant finanzwelt aber anscheinend bin
ich brauche meine hand ein sprecher
die sache ist wenn ich jetzt falsch wie
gehasst einfach schon gewonnen ich weiß
mich max eppelein von bernd erdmann wir
auch unserem land wirklich auch nicht
die wenig kraft und mit dem herz am
überlegen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du wirklich
das nein nein hat er nicht dass er immer
irgendwo irgendwas machen vor allem
während du gelebt hat ich habe nur heute
bekomme ich noch einen gegenstand und
wenn ich ihn habe bekomme ich die proben
finden ohnehin hält wenn er richtig ist
schon sehr roh typ von mir mehr hierzu
ein
du hast gewonnen' im fall der 15
wesentliches mittelpunkt handling oder
drogen bei meinem glück befehl okay ich
mache mir natürlich braucht
was ich in der hand halte ist angry
birds augenbrauen
ich weiß auch dass für die keine haft
dann würden wir nur eine verkleidung
abschlägen auf die augenbrauen waren
aber ich sage nein hat für mich ja da
würde ich sagen dass du weißt dass du
okay
warum wenn ich nur dran aber es wird
noch ich heute noch einfach hoch und du
musst noch entwickeln ich hatte in
meiner hand eine gut für spannende tüte
einen kurs spannbetttuch okay ich weiß
was gemeint ich weiß dass du das
zusammen bei ikea gekauft haben weist
aber als du warst auch im schlaf erhält
kommt alles passt zusammen aber ich
denke mir einfach dass das damit würde
ich ja noch in der nacht nach dem spiel
auf das wir euch gefallen hat hashtag
ich brauche noch eine mauer kommentare
gehören in die hölle
widerstand macht gut und lassen